welcome to the chessable monsters
all right I'll start again
respectful of Yan's great ability and
um
yeah
[Music]
sorry about that that means that uh
Geary status is after preliminaries
I'm sorry sorry
I don't know my phone just went crazy
um
there's a hair from my chest but what
sticking out
two days of the final and uh
that was me when I came home from the
bachelorette party yeah
he feels that this is confidence
building this is something that it takes
with him
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
can we hear it in The Voice
I am inevitable yes I am inevitable yeah
I agree with you I think this is just a
technical draw I mean even if you remove
uh yeah one black porn and one white
Pawn in a lot of positions that is a
technical draw the black king butt and
check followed by another check in the
perfect battle game I mean all of sports
[Laughter]
they won one game each and of course
some tea and we're gonna need it today
David
I'm so sorry
I shouldn't put it in my mouth among
this is grabbing a hot dog here and he's
not quite up for talking right now
[Applause]
and
yeah right now Mama door if he's turned
it around and now
um
my mind has gone blank a little bit
um I wrote a studor this is the I I just
got a bit put off by Richard rapport's
face
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go last tour for me
[Music]
this chair definitely has seen some
success
[Music]
Magnus Carlsen who finished the day with
a win against congratulations Magnus
oh we didn't check oh okay that's a
surprise yes
uh surprised uh Magnus what happened in
your game against me to Ginger DM what
I'm watching from the final who's Harry
the horn attack what should Judah do if
he's worse in them
the person that wins this uh auction
what will they get
night with me
la la
[Music]